there are two kinds of people in the
world the first of the people who see a
challenge and they run from it they tell
themselves that they don't have the
experience to win they don't have the
education to win they don't have the
money to win they don't have the right
family lived in the right country I know
the right people to win they come up
with a million reasons why they will
never win and so they lose the reality
is all the reasons you believe you won't
win deep down is just fear disguised as
practicality you might be an underdog
now who nobody believes will make it but
the only person who is really holding
you back is yourself remember that guy
who gave up neither does anybody else
the people around you also tell you that
you'll fail they say that you're crazy
for having a big dream they tell you
that be more realistic be smart
take the safe route just like they did
so you can live a life just like them is
that what you want the second kind of
people are those who see big obstacles
as challenges it's a temporary setback
not a final declaration they see a
mountain in front of them and instead of
thinking they're stuck where they are
they start looking for a ways to climb
over it they believe they can climb over
it they surround themselves with people
ideas and energy that supports them
climbing over it in their mind they've
already climbed over and are on the
other side underdogs are stronger
because of the adversity they fight
through underdogs don't pay attention to
the odds and just go out and do it
underdogs give their best so they don't
live with regret for the rest of their
lives there's always gonna be some with
more money than you better looks and you
more connections than you more education
than you but you can still win because
you've got the heart you've got the
drive you've got the hustle the throne
belongs to the people who believe they
deserve it so get out of your own way
stop holding yourself back and go get
what's yours